work with me DUI you still don't get it  there's nothing you can do Batman please  please anything you want  give him up and I'll make that danger go  away no I can't  you've seen this machines you're  completely insane  no I am death  Midler terrorized this city long before  you were back then to have him returned  it's unsettling is the leaf clues at all  his crime scenes always thought he was  smarter than the people trying to catch  him  [Applause]  you should have called us before going  in Gordon Waller this city is about to  find itself in a crisis the likes of  which it's never known the criminally  insane you're drawn to that aren't you I  told you I'd see you again didn't I  need that favor you owe me we all wear  mess  [Music]  Gotham's criminals have become zealots  and thugs in shoe suits  very impressed  I'm not impressed I want to commemorate  the moment smile